hey leute cedric hier wow lang ist's her
für die leute die mich nicht kennen ich
bin zwei drag ich hab das vor circa
einem halben jahr hier auf klicks um die
serie what's on gemacht wo ich über
zukunftstechnologien gesprochen habe und
alles was unser leben in der zukunft
verändern könnte seitdem bin ich aber
auf meinem eigenen kanal doktor watson
wo ich jeden donnerstag wissenschafts
videos hochladen und christoph hat mich
jetzt gebeten wahrscheinlich aus reiner
nostalgie ein samstag die top five news
zu übernehmen und das mache ich
natürlich mega gerne christoph also
herzlich willkommen zu den klicks um top
news
erste experimente mit tesla vor esa
wissenschaftler der rice university
forschen an selbst konstruieren den
nanoröhren ein starkes elektrisches feld
sorgt dafür dass sich dieser haufen
nanoröhren von alleine zu einem seil
verbindet und elektrizität erzeugt der
effekt konnte genutzt werden um zwei
leds miteinander zu verbinden und zum
leuchten zu bringen
das elektrische feld wird durch eine
tesla spule erzeugt die den benötigten
strom induziert
es ist das erste mal dass ein
elektrisches feld auf diese art und
weise benutzt wird und laut der forscher
hat das phänomen ein großes potenzial im
bereich der regenerativen medizin
man könnte sich zum beispiel vorstellen
einem patienten nanoröhren zu spritzen
die sich dann im körper aufbauen und
dort die organe unterstützen selbst
konstruieren die objekte formen und
geräte könnten sogar zu einer eigenen
branche werden
jetzt wird aber erstmal weiter geforscht
um die möglichkeiten dieser technologie
auszuloten
spacex will bereits 2018 zum mars die
weltraum firma spacex von firmengründer
ihle maske hat pläne bereits in zwei
jahren die ersten flüge zum mars zu
absolvieren
wenn sie diese pläne umsetzen können
wären sie damit in ihrem zeitplan für
den ersten bemannten marsflug noch vor
der nasa für die flügel will das private
raumfahrtunternehmen wohl seine felton
harry rakete benutzen eine modifizierte
rakete die im grunde aus drei
zusammengesetzten feld hinein raketen
besteht
eines der größten probleme bei dem
versuch menschen auf den markt zu
bringen sind die vielen tonnen
versorgungsweg widmen
diese müssen bei der ankünfte
astronauten bereits sicher auf dem mars
gelandet worden seien weil die
marsatmosphäre aber nur circa 100 der
dichte unserer atmosphäre hat ist es
beinahe unmöglich mehrere tonnen
material einfach per fallschirm herunter
fallen zu lassen
deswegen testet spacex gerade ihre red
dragon kapseln die mit acht sogenannten
super draco boostern ausgestattet sind
diese werden dann ähnlich wie bei den
landungen der verein raketen vor dem
aufprall eine große menge schub erzeugen
und hoffentlich die landung abfedern
mehr informationen zu den geplanten
flügen will das unternehmen erst im
september veröffentlichen
aber eins ist sicher space extrem
menschen auf den mars bringen und könnte
dabei sogar noch schneller sein als die
nasa die erst für die 2030er jahre die
ersten bemannten flüge geplant hat
gedanken gesteuertes drohnen rennen vor
wenigen tagen wurde in der university of
florida das weltweit erste
gedankengesteuerte drohenden rennen
abgehalten
die studenten steuerten die drohnen mit
eeg headsets die extra auf die gehirne
der teilnehmer kalibriert wurden diese
headsets können die gehirnaktivität der
neuronen durch den schädel messen und
muster erkennen
man muss nur daran denken etwas nach
vorne zu drücken und schon bewegt sich
die drohne entsprechend in letzter zeit
werden in diesem bereich immer mehr
fortschritte gemacht
zuletzt konnte ein gelähmter durch ein
gehirn implantat wieder objekte greifen
und sogar guitar hero spielen
zurzeit ist diese methode der steuerung
zwar noch recht unbeholfen aber wer weiß
wie schnell sich die technologie
entwickelt und für was sie alles gut
sein könnte neue messmethode für
entfernte sterne gefunden
das hier ist y wie 16b ein stern der
circa 400 lichtjahre von unserer erde
entfernt ist
um den stern herum ist eine
protoplanetaren scheibe eine mischung
aus staub und kleineren objekten die
sich häufig bei der entstehung von neuen
sternen phorms und vielleicht der
ursprung von planeten sein könnte diese
könnten entstehen wenn größere objekte
in den staub nebel geraten und sich
immer mehr masse um die objekte
ansammelt im seo physik journal wurde
jetzt eine neue methode der messung
veröffentlicht die es uns erlaubt
protoplanetaren scheiben besser zu
messen und zu verstehen
da der stern mit einer million jahren
noch recht jung ist gibt es häufiger
schlagartige ausbrüche auf der
oberfläche die zu einer veränderung der
helligkeit führen die wissenschaftler
können diese veränderungen messen und
warten danach auf eine zweite
veränderung
diese zweite veränderung soll von der
protoplanetaren scheibe reflektiert
worden sein und braucht somit länger bis
sie unsere erde erreicht aus dem
zeitunterschied von 72 sekunden konnte
man dann errechnen dass der abstand von
stern und scheibe bei circa 0,08
astronomischen einheiten liegen muss ob
protoplanetaren scheiben häufig der
ursprung von planeten sind die dann um
diesen stern kreisen muss noch genauer
erforscht werden
aber die tatsache dass wir aus 400
lichtjahren entfernung so kleine
abstände messen können ist erstaunlich
hawking strahlung endlich bewiesen
schwarze löcher verlieren ständig
energie
je kleiner sie sind desto mehr energie
und damit masse strahlen sie ab jede
schwarze loch wird aufgrund dieser
tatsache irgendwann wieder verschwinden
das zumindest ist die theorie des
physiker stephen hawking die er vor 42
jahren aufgestellt hat der aber bis
heute nicht bewiesen werden konnte
das problem ist dass diese strahlen
geringem maße auftritt und aus unserer
entfernung zu den nächsten schwarzen
löchern quasi nicht zu messen ist aber
wenn unsere messgeräte nicht nah genug
an ein schwarzes loch rankommen können
dann kommt das schwarze loch eben zu uns
das dachte sich zumindest chef
steinhauer der technical university und
erzeugt in seinem labor sein eigenes
akustisches schwarzes loch akustische
schwarze löcher funktionieren ungefähr
so wie reguläre schwarze löcher nur eben
mit schall der in das schwarze loch
hinein fällt ist für immer verloren aber
wir jetzt herausgefunden wurde verliert
diese art von schwarzen löchern energie
in form von photonen von ihnen sind
quasi das gegenstück zu photonen es sind
quanten und diese kommen eben doch aus
dem schwarzen loch wieder heraus wie das
experiment zeigt in den nächsten wochen
und monaten müssten diese daten noch
überprüft und das experiment wiederholt
werden
aber solltest dein hobby hawking
strahlung wirklich bewiesen haben da
kann sich namensgeber stephen hawking
wohl bald endlich über seinen ersten
nobelpreis freuen denn er hat
erstaunlicherweise noch nie einen für
seine unzähligen errungenschaften
erhalten
schwarze löcher sind ein super
kompliziertes aber auch mega spannendes
thema und wenn ihr mehr darüber wissen
wollt dann schaut euch am besten
dieses video hier an was passiert in
einem schwarzen loch erkläre ich wie
schwarze löcher entstehen und was
passiert wenn man in 1 hineinfällt und
ich kläre ein paar missverständnisse auf
die erstaunlich viele leute über
schwarze löcher glauben
ansonsten mache ich aber auch andere
videos click gerne mal auf mein kanal da
lade ich jeden donnerstag ein video hoch
und jetzt bin ich auf eure meinung
gespannt welche möglichkeiten bietet die
tester vor reese in der zukunft und wer
wird als erstes auf dem mars landen
space ex die nasa oder noch jemand
anderes
schreibt mir eure meinung dazu unten in
die kommentare und ansonsten danke 1
christoph für diesen kleinen
gastauftritt hier
ich verabschiede mich von euch bis dann
euer cedric